you've been following this story about
the mumford and sons things obviously
you were in a
you're in a band i guess this might have
a special place in your heart
yeah yeah that this one's like funny
because it is like
the truth is if you're in a band
and you're going to get out there with
your dissonant opinions
you better not be the friggin you know
playing the
the the cheese grader with a stick
you can't have guy number 12 in the band
you know what i mean you better you
better not be the watch more than like
backup washboard player
you're gonna get out there with your
freaking opinions especially
so you know it's just like at a company
right like imagine you had like
10 founders of a company and one guy's
out there so
i get why if they're like hey all we
have to do is
shut up it's like you're going to get
out there and like we're getting all
this heat and you're saying
saying all this stuff because you want
to you know be this guy that's part of
the culture war
and you're ruining our lives listen
that's what we were saying because he
posted andy knows
a book or whatever that's that was his
whole thing he said andy knows book was
good against
why antifa is bad but imagine like the
rest of them like behind closed doors
they're like yeah yeah i mean we all
love andy know
like imagine the rest yeah but we
weren't stupid enough to tweet about it
yeah
yeah yeah if you go to their dressing
room it's just like all of them
photos of andy on the wall all the
inside of the two of us has got like
there's a shrine to him at the end of
the night but they're just like we have
to we can't
say this publicly of course we all love
andy no
so that was i i don't know or or they
all or they were just like sick of this
guy's [ __ ] so it's hard to know
what the scenario is but i would say
that in
in my opinion in a band or a tv show or
a job or anything
it's like listen if you are not the
singer songwriter in a band
you won the lottery like you
legitimately
you were friends with a guy who got
really famous and now you're a
millionaire because of it
that's legitimately what happened so
right-wing or left-wing or opinions or
anything like that like
you do what he says like that's in my
opinion
i i would kind of uh i've seen a lot of
musicians that get famous on
both sides that they start thinking
they're you know more important like
this guy's like
you know i need to get out there with my
opinions it's like your opinions you're
like the
you know like the spoon player from
slipknot
number guy number 21 from slipknot yeah
yeah yeah yeah guy who plays the 19th
garbage lid
yeah yeah yeah it was interesting so i
had a look at this i look at this
article and he said um
this is talking about winston smith he
blamed a viral mob for his decision to
leave the band permanently
i failed to foresee that commenting on a
book critical of the far left could be
interpreted as approval of the equally
abhorrent far
right then he said winston said his
mumford and sonned
band mate had asked him to stay with
them after the tweet
but when he decided to step back from
the band another viral mob came after me
this time for the sin of apologizing
it's like once you've put yourself in
there you're gonna get wrecked no matter
where you are
he was he was literally doing the thing
where he's like oh
crap i'll apologize and everyone's like
yo why'd you apologize he's like okay
don't apologize there's only two buttons
i've only got two buttons this guy
doesn't have the temperament to be you
know and even if you read what he says
it's like
i agree kind of it's like you know he's
even what he just said now he's like
well i guess like me not being you know
left-wing makes me right-wing now and
you're like yeah you're right that's how
they see it
that is correct that's it it literally
says it here being labeled erroneously
just goes to show how
binary political discourse has become i
criticized the left
so i must be the right or something
like you don't you're not aware of this
like this is
like this is just news to you now like
this guy's gonna be
now now what he goes on like the dave
reuben tour like saying [ __ ] that we all
like thought in 2013 i apologize on the
view
goes and apologizes on the view or you
go
because the other song no man i i
obviously it sucks like
if you're you know whatever some guy in
some band and you're famous and you got
all these opinions and you
post anything you think in your life's
over but
uh that is that is the situation so i i
i'm a big
and you know what i mean i shouldn't
trash him because he goes this is what i
want to do and now i'm going to
go say what i want to do and he made
maybe he's pretty rich right now so to
be honest like
maybe there's nothing more to be said
than that's what this guy didn't you
know now he can
go start his one-man ukulele show that
won't
and you know he could write a he can
write like you can do reaction videos to
andy know
but
but this is the problem with like
uh the conservative people where they're
just like constantly flabbergasted with
journalists like they'll be like
these journalists are liars and you're
like yes that's the
that's the situation it's like okay now
now that we're on the same page on
planet earth
you understand that these people aren't
journalists and they lie
and if you're and if you're anyone smart
like if you run a company you understand
that like hey how can i use these
journalists
if i have something and by the way a lot
of these people are the same you go
if i if i want to use you like the dark
arts
for my company for my thing i need to
find a message that resonates with what
you're trying to say
and if you're like a big company right
now you go okay all these publications
want to say that you know
fat girls are hot so it's like i need to
make myself have fat girl stuff it's
like
if you're tucker carlson i need to you
know say some [ __ ] about cancer culture
if i want you to promote my
like so yes all of these journalists are
liars now
now okay now we're on the same page how
do you what are we doing
and i think that for me i mean try to i
try to make funny stuff right
you know it sounds like you try to have
interesting conversations and try
whatever right but it is it's like
it is like i i've relatives that are
like this and it's like they get
fixated on like it'll be
the equivalent of like they're dating a
girl and they're like oh this girl just
is like this and you're like yes that's
how she is that's correct you know what
i mean
like they're not changing like no that's
what journalists are they're they're all
liars yes correct
politicians are liars so what what now
i uh does that make sense yeah
absolutely mama i think it's
the mad thing is i can see it from both
sides because i can understand why
is a a conservative you know a a daily
wire
guy a shapiro kind of guy tucker carlson
kind of guy you think well this is
unfair
the press continue to say things that we
know
are wrong logically they don't make
sense they're hypocritical they're in
inconsistent or whatever so you think
well okay
i understand that highlighting the
hypocrisy might be compelling to you
and it might actually garner views but
on
the other side of the argument it
doesn't seem to be actually changing
anything it's not moving
anything at all so you just think well i
mean it makes for kind of like
fun woke bashing viewing
if you have that let that sort of
political leaning and you agree with
that
but it's not going to further your
agenda because you've done this
3 000 times before and it doesn't appear
to make any
any difference you're right this is the
this is the status quo this is how
everything works it's written into the
source code of the operating system that
you you and everybody else is living in
but the problem is that because the left
dominates the media and they have
control of these narratives mostly
usually that you have a lot of sort of
reactionaries from the right that says
oh well we
this is terrible it's outrageous we
can't have this
yeah yeah no that exactly and it
and to me it's it's kind of i guess the
reason it
um i don't know like even right now like
as i'm saying i'm kind of like
like maybe going too hard on some of
these people if you want to say but it's
the same way when you go
remember when like there are valid like
criticisms of donald trump as a
president
but when everyone was out there being
insane being like he's worse than hitler
you kind of you know most normal people
i think when someone goes
i have a bunch of things about trump
yeah
yeah join the channel shut up shut up
yeah like you know what i mean
and it's the same thing with this where
it's like
it's like uh grifting almost you know
where they just like
take real issues in it and then uh
bastardize them into like partisan
things where it's like no this doesn't
have to be like a partisan
thing that like you know uh youtube
censorship and
obviously it is probably more
conservatives more but it's like
it's everyone and it's like there are
certain issues where it's like that's
why it's hard to touch them because
like abortion is just a partisan issue
if you're this you're this if it's this
this
there's no change in anyone's mind and
it's like they
they try to use the dark arts of like
galvanizing their base
on these issues and just turn them into
partisan issues when like a lot of times
they kind of didn't have to be
and i think like comedy would be a
perfect example it's like dude edgy
comedy shouldn't be like a left-wing
right-wing thing
and i understand that it kind of is but
it won't that's going to swing back like
and so i don't really want to be part of
this like
movement to being like if you like edgy
comedy that's conservative and you're
like
no you you want it to be that because
you want to like attach yourself to this
like cultural power right now
for views so i guess i like resent like
uh like drifting by like machine
to like uh gulp uh
cultural movements and then uh try to
use them for like political reasons well
it's kind of like the boy that cried
wolf
in one way you know if if everybody's
racist then nobody is racist
if everything is racist then nothing is
racist and
you're right as well after a while the
donald trump stories you just thought
you can't one-up this anymore there's no
more
shy of getting into his sexual kinks
which will kind of
already got did you know there's almost
no way that you can take this to that
one ups the story so that people will
actually take notice
and when there's so much of a flood you
can't what are you gonna
what are you gonna do now what are you
gonna talk about now but there is
nowhere else for you to scale this up
and um you're right what happens is that
legitimate concerns get lost within a
a big avalanche of people jumping onto
something that they know is just going
to get agreement from their side and
generate clicks yeah i think so
where it's yeah that's where it becomes
that struggle like you said once you
i think a lot of people like you know
the jim jeffries even like yo he got
famous off this like gun control bit and
then it was like before he knew it he's
like this leveling pundit right like
before that he was like you know getting
drunk and having sex with girls like
you know kind of i don't know like
australian frat sort of
comedy or whatever you want to call it
right but which i like but it just you
know
you have one one thing and it becomes
that and i kind of so you do you have to
you kind of fight back against it and
make you know make other things
and you uh try to decide what you want
to be and
i don't know there isn't like a right
answer i think that's like the
whole you know being an artist part but
if you're just trying to make as much
money as possible as quick as possible
or
grow as quick as possible i think you
just end up doing that right
did you see what the couple who
came out of their house with guns last
year
mccloskeys yeah haven't they released
like a brand of hot sauce or something
what have they done
they've i swear that they've
merchandised themselves somehow what
have they done it's like i've seen
silhouettes of them posted on mugs or
something
dude that's so funny like having people
over and or going to someone's house and
bringing your leg on mcglove
one of the same things right you've got
someone that's kind of found some sort
of success
a little bit of clout online like
okay how long can we rinse this for the
silhouette of him and his wife stood
with an ar-15 outside of their house and
some hot sauce toilet roll we got
condoms
yeah trigger you know triggered hot
sauce or whatever right
but um there was yeah i'm not triggered
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace